[Music]
you know terry trump's impeachment trial
starts next week and
he's acting all mad about it but frankly
i think he loves that he got impeached a
second time
i agree by the end of his term his
behavior was so egregious
it was like he was daring them to
impeach him again
yeah i hear what you saying dog it's
like trump was all like
hey girl i'm a bad boy
looking for some attention you've got to
give me what i want
i've been doing dirt since dirt was a
thing one could do
when skipping out on barrels getting on
my thrills
from handing out ious i've been hyping
up the craziest to the point of
resurrection
and i must confess i'm a mess i'm only
doing it to get your attention
[Music]
i've been a bad boy but you could bring
me joy
if only you were willing to
impeach
[Music]
[Music]
till i
[Music]
it's time to practice what you've been
preaching
let's have a second
[Music]
corrupt as hell i truly thought i was
the [ __ ]
i reckon you could impeach me in a
second
cause all my lawyers quit
take what you heard believe
[Music]
when people try to override all my veto
two paper towels
in puerto rico tax evasion rape
accusations there was even witness
intimidation you see me in peace
girl you've got to impeach me
stop me and teach me right and teach me
nerdy baby
impeach
[Music]
it's time to practice what you've been
freezing
let's have a second impeachment
you